I don't know you mean help of like a
little spicy thing or if we're going to
establish rapid yeah I was taking on
your roof or need help with anything I
probably like no baby I'm not sure
because I have your cool with Cameron
I'm just you know sustained and ear feel
useless so we're going to be going to
see family the draft now he is super
super famous and here he is you only
done difficult yeah yeah yeah I can't
wait to feed him he can like lettuce
yeah he like to let it be his tongue I
was looking at him on Instagram earlier
this morning you know why they have a
black on now because it would look like
sunscreen
yes it's called the Malibu wine Safari
you basically see a giraffe season
animals drink wine okay
licensed by my way it's not just dry in
the mall oh yeah superficial he felt
sorry if I'm drinking and a wonderful
mediocre here's Mike
[Music]
go through the gate 16 lead I don't know
I'm never been here before
family in the wine she was over there
you can say hello to our American bison
family Chipotle and barbecue folks and
their little son behind them is baby
sliders luckily they don't know their
own names to give you guys some
perspective of how big displaces some
saddle box it really Phegley the style
requests directly in the middle the
castle rock all the way on the other
side this is all owned by Rollins
monthly 700 acres those are stars
pendulum on the modem we all have a cell
wall of some work laundering with a
great family am I ready for this
hairspray you don't have to you can grab
a few to easily be them one at a time
the can't show these two cute wanna go
see are you following this is al
know here's an alpaca hanging with the
llama so you're very cool yeah many
press over here really this is so cool
use the pipette the alpacas can now I
will use a zebra zebra is a mama zebra
and a baby D because it's so cool this
is always privately-owned is Incan tours
they have a winery they've got
everything here yeah be bored horses
they have an avocado farm and cross the
street they have a winery if you can be
like tastings there this is incredible
Oh baby you don't see my cake
that's baby girls a green over there
she's actually born of Halloween oh if
you want to see her
definitely can to break up the lettuce
bow here you go aiseesoft my snapshot
specs or even are they on
[Music]
when I study unblown it is it Stan the
man oh it's so cute to scan when he's
been in the hangover she's doing
commercials but she just saw that he's
actually retired because he's too tall
to fit in the screen now so this little
boys living retired live later it's
modulating the chance
oh my god your mouth or how totally
reject my kids was also so I was the
dream and uh
was a home again syrustey
you feel any better hope you can help
carry so many family and you've got to
go on from the pack am i should I give
him a kiss for heating a cocoa the first
time when I saw you I thought my my
you invaded throw away left behind
[Music]
okay where happens back on the bunch and
I think that's it back up all of the
wine coolers they gave you a super small
samples so they're actually loving a lot
of one consumed if there is six
different types there is three white and
three red but it is a little tasting
about who is so much fun and family so
cute you can actually rent out a little
cabin for three night minimum and you
can get to see family daily Stanley
daily oh my god so said agent cuddles a
little Standa Manny so cute and now
we're going to go to the mallet and cafe
I have blogs in there before but just
place so cute
hope that open comes you're probably so
much
[Music]
we were trying to play test but I'm not
sure if I made some strategic moves or
made it worse just making videos over
here okay we've got a diagonal these are
going to go very far or we're gonna have
a worse season when we can you can go
like that baby right yeah right you're
right sorry that I came here to just
farm for teenie we're here for like
three or four hours
someone's going down and we decided are
that going to be a birthday I would
entertain either way he can I'm proven
that even though I'm really thankful and
I know I'm rejecting your soul our soul
Wow and we were to do he was outside
food also